be ramaswami posted this over the
weekend this tweet he says on day one
instantly fire 50% of federal
bureaucrats here's how if your social
security number ends in an odd number
you're fired that downsizes government
by half absolutely nothing will break as
a result it doesn't violate civil
services rules because Mass layoffs are
exempt shut it down then he continued to
elaborate this avoids Civil Service
protections no bureaucrat can claim
their firings were politically motivated
further firings can be executed with a
chisel but step one needs to be
unrestrained chainsaw or else it just
won't
happen um now this plan's getting a you
know reaction from people online and
first let me just say that the idea that
we should just fire 50% of federal
bureaucrats is totally outrageous and
insane and I agree a lot with a lot of
what ramaswami says but this is just
nonsense
50% it should be
90% but I guess 50 is a good start um so
as as a start I love the idea lots of
people have bristled at it as you might
imagine including plenty of alleged
conservatives are are upset about this
you know the people who have been
talking about shrinking the size of
government for decades and then someone
comes along and says all right let's do
it guys and those same people say no no
no wait I not like that I mean okay well
what way do you want to do it oh not at
all the way the way I want to do this
thing is to not do it that was my
preferred strategy um and this is what
you have to understand every
Republican for my entire life has run on
a plan and before my life began has run
on a plan to cut the size of government
and reduce spending and all the rest of
it and none of them have done it okay
none of them none of them have even
tried to do it that's that's not even
like they've made an attempt none of
them have even cut the size of
government or cut spending by
like
5% instead they've all increased it
every single
one um none of them have reduced the
size of the Behemoth Federal bureaucracy
they they've really just added to it and
that's because at this point actually
cutting this thing down really making a
dent would require a drastic action like
this and so um if you support a
candidate who is not
suggesting seemingly drastic Extreme
Measures then that is someone who is not
actually going to do this at all because
that's the only way to do it this
thing the federal bureaucracy is so big
and so unwieldy and so outrageously
enormous that you can't help to achieve
anything by making surgical Cuts with a
scalpel and again even that no
Republican president has done but but
but that wouldn't be enough
because whatever little lump you cut off
will just grow back before dinner
time that's how huge this thing is it's
a huge self-replicating organism and if
you're not taking a chainsaw to this
thing um an unrestrained chainsaw as Viv
R Swami says then you aren't doing
anything do you
know T we on the subject do you know how
many people work for the federal
government right now the federal
government has close two 3 million
employees and that is just the civilian
work force okay so that's not everybody
who works for the that's not even close
to everybody who works for the federal
government but the civilian Workforce is
close to three
million
employees so if you cut half of them you
would still have over a million people
on the payroll you would still have more
people than work for Google Apple
Facebook combined times two if you cut
half you'd still have enough people to
fill like 14 NFL
stadiums isn't that enough how could
that not be enough I mean can we get by
can we get by with 14 NFL stadiums full
of people running the
government
um there are so many and and here's the
other fact not only can you and should
you cut half of the federal Workforce
but if you did
none of us would notice a difference I'm
telling you right now if they were just
to cut
50% and not tell us you no one you would
never know you would never know that
they could come back 10 years later and
say oh by the way you know we cut 50% of
the workforce uh 10 years ago you oh
really like your life if it changes at
all it would be for the
better um but really there'd be just be
no difference you would never
notice okay if you don't work in the
government
not that I have but I'm I'm telling you
you have no idea how useless most of
these people
are not all of them but but most of them
there are so many I mean thousands and
thousands of federal jobs that serve no
purpose uh other than just for their own
sake and and they help no one they do
nothing it is redundancy on top of
redundancy on top of redundancy we have
entire agencies entire uh uh
departments entire bureaucracies within
the greater bureaucracy that could be
wiped off the face of the planet
tomorrow and you would never
know now I read somewhere
that um the bureaucracy that ran the
Roman Empire had like 20 or 30,000
employees which was a lot at the time
Time by comparison though that's only a
little more than currently run the city
of
Boston okay 30,000 to run an
Empire the biggest empire on the globe
at the time and and uh now we need
30,000 to run Boston and not run It Well
by the way gr Canyon University is an
affordable private Christian University
based in Phoenix Arizona they're
dedicated to making education fit in to
your already busy schedule which is why
they offer 270 of their academic
programs online from scholarships to
academic support gcu's graduation team
provides you with the personal support
you need to obtain your goals gcu's
online programs offer you the freedom to
earn your degree on your own time from
wherever you are GCU is praise for its
culture of community giving an impact
they integrate the free market system
and a welcoming Christian worldview into
all of their academic programs achieve
your goals with a personalized plan and
a supportive team behind you find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
we have 3 million people running our
country and that and that does not
include the millions upon Millions
collectively who work for States and and
and uh cities across the country so
that's not all the government workers
it's not even close alt together okay
City
Federal uh state government all together
only
civilians that's something like 20
million okay it's actually more than
that but about 20
million and and that means that like one
out of every 15 people in the country
works for the government at some level
one out of every 15 I'm doing a lot of
math here this is getting pretty
dangerous I'm going to get a fact check
but uh I'm pretty confident in these num
the point is it's a lot okay it is just
it is a
lot way it's so much that the the saying
a lot doesn't even come close to
covering
it and
um
and these people are not working for
free by the way just so you know this is
billions of dollar I mean billions and
billions of dollars that we are spending
just on the payroll for all these
people most of whom their jobs could not
exist and it would only make your life
better if you noticed at all it would
only be for the better
so yeah should we go in and cut 50% yes
absolutely
and if that seems extreme to you exactly
because that's the situation that we're
in if it seems if that's if you bristle
at that then it only shows that you
don't understand you do not understand
how bad it is and just how much you are
being
scammed like most of these jobs I say
they serve no purpose that's not exactly
true most of these purpose the most of
these jobs serve the purpose of giving
jobs so that other people in government
can give jobs to their friends and
family and everything else it's it's
just it's a giant nepotism
program that you are
funding like you can barely afford to
buy groceries at the grocery store for
your family and you are funding this
massive welfare scheme for federal
bureaucrats um and once you understand
that and you hear 50% being cut your
only reaction is mine which is like
that's not enough I I'll take it but
that's only that's just a start you know
50% then let's cut another 50 and let's
keep
going and I think every other uh
candidate in the race right now should
should should be asked do you support
that plan and if you don't why what is
your
plan okay do you have a plan for getting
rid of 50% of these bureaucrats because
if you don't you better come up with one
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there